hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
wedelt heute gibt es mal wieder etwas
türkisches und war es ganz schnelles und
zwar gibt es heute ein würdig
normalerweise wird würdig aus selbst
gemachtem luft gemacht aber das hat
etwas schneller gehen soll
mache ich das aus fertigen you've got
blättern und zwar sehen die so aus das
sind drei stücke in einer packung und
ich brauche davon eben zwei päckchen
natürlich kann man die auch selber
machen ich zeige euch das auch mal aber
nicht jeder hat auch das werkzeug daheim
um die selber zu machen deswegen finde
ich es eine ganz gute alternative und
samira gibt dieses völlig auf ganz arg
und deswegen mache ich das eben auch mal
ganz gern aus den fertigen blättern und
außer diesen news.com blättern braucht
die jetzt hier noch folgende zutaten und
zwar habe ich hier 400 gramm joghurt das
ist ein zehnprozentiger naturjoghurt
dann 200 milliliter milch zweier dann
für die füllung etwas käse und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier 700 gramm käse aus
kuhmilch dann etwas petersilie die weiß
bei mir im tiefkühlfach und die weiß
schon klein geschnitten dann brauche ich
später etwa 50 milliliter öl und noch
etwas pfeffer und chili und zum
bestreuen noch sesam könner und
schwarzkümmel schwarz kümmerliches genau
die lüfterblätter müsste jetzt einfach
mal auspacken und dann kurz liegen
lassen
die werden im kühlschrank gelagert
es sind dann halt so ein vakuum hat und
jetzt kann ich schon mal die füllung bzw
diesen guss verbreiten weil die blätter
sind jetzt ziemlich trocken wenn man
sich selber macht sind sie etwas
feuchter aber trotzdem brauchen wir dann
eben etwas um sie damit zu bestreichen
und deswegen führe ich jetzt hier den
joghurt und die eier mit der mädels
es kommt hier noch bisschen pfeffer salz
brauchen wir nicht denn der käse ist das
schon salzig genug und ein bisschen
chili dann nehme ich jetzt auch nicht so
viel weil es mir später noch mit essen
will und die marktplätze so ich kann ich
das kurz zur seite stellen und den käse
zerkleinern geht mit den händen oder
einfach mit so einem löffel
jetzt kommt die petersilie noch mit rein
jetzt könnte bereits die juka blätter
auseinandernehmen
die sind auch ziemlich groß
und jetzt bestreichen wir die mit dieser
erfüllung also mit diesem bus
und dann kommt jetzt der käse drauf und
den verteilt ihr am besten mit den
händen der so ziemlich klebrig und der
kommt einfach so grob überall hin nur
nicht zu viel aber so schön verteilen
und jetzt wird die eine hälfte über die
andere geklappt wenn es da mal reißt es
ist gar nicht schlimm könnte einfach
wieder zusammenflicken jetzt wird es so
ein bisschen gerafft
und kommt dann direkt auf ein backblech
da gibt es eigentlich keine richtige
form
ihr müsst es einfach zusammenraffen und
dann rein leben und so mache ich das
jetzt auch mit dem restlichen und von
diesem kursmuster so ungefähr ein glas
voll aufheben
das brauchen wir später noch von darüber
streichen
habe ich hier noch ein bisschen von dem
bus übrig und da gebe ich das öl mit
rein dann wird es schön verrührt und es
kommt jetzt über das ganze perfekt rüber
und jetzt wird mit schwarzkümmel und
sesam bestreut und dann kommt sie in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 10 grad
für ungefähr 30 minuten nach so schöne
goldbraune oberfläche und unten ist es
auch schön goldbraun und dann lasse ich
es erstmal so etwa 15 minuten abkühlen
bevor ich dann schneide
das boarding ist jetzt fertig und ich
hab jetzt zehn minuten abkühlen lassen
und am besten lässt sich das jetzt mit
einer schere schneiden natürlich könnte
auch ein messer benutzen
aber ich finde mit nachschärfen kommt
man da einfach besser durch und ihr seht
jetzt auch schon die oberfläche ist
jetzt richtig schön goldbraun und auch
sehr knusprig sind ja auch so richtig
schöne dünne teigschichten
und ich setze jetzt hier auch eine
servierplatten man könnte auch mal das
innere sehen
im innern ist nämlich das völlig richtig
schön weich da ist dann auch diese
cremige füllung unten ist es auch weich
und oben an der oberfläche eben knusprig
und bei uns gibt es zeitgleich einen tee
mit dazu gerne kanada jetzt zum beispiel
auch tomaten oder gurken mit dazu
schneiden und oliven passen immer gut
dazu in der türkei oder halt auch bei
uns im türkischen gibt es dann oft zur
mittagszeit so zum tee oder auch mal
gerne abends wenn einfach mal besuch
kommt und ja ich hole es gleich die
sanierer von kindergarten ab die freut
sich da schon den ganzen tag darauf habe
ich mich heute morgen erzählt dass ich
das heute mache und wenn ihr das
nachmachen volt gehen einfach auf meinem
blog auf sell ist blog.de
da stehen noch mal die genauen zutaten
mengen und die rezept angaben
und ich freue mich schon aufs nächste
mal bis dann tschüss